la prison est en train de devenir un
énorme asile psychiatrique non pas à
ciel ouvert mais si elle fermait on
évalue à plus de 30%
le nombre de gens souffrant de troubles
graves psychiatrique qui sont enfermés
en prison
faisant jouer au surveillant comme au
détenu le rôle d'infirmier psychiatrique
ce qu'ils ne sont pas
on a des témoignages de détenus qui nous
racontent que se levant la nuit pour
faire pipi se heurte au corps
pendu d'un coup détenu où il nous
raconte des scènes épouvantables de
détenus qu'on leur impose dans leur
cellules et qui hurlent du matin au soir
et dont ils ne veulent plus et qui
finissent par repousser de leurs
cellules
ils ont honte de cette réaction enfin et
tout ce qui est fait pour
tout ce qui est préconisé par l'article
707 du code de procédure pénale à savoir
mener en prison une vie le plus proche
possible de celle de la société
afin de mener dehors une vie réinsérer
et responsable et exemples d'infraction
tout ça est bafoué du matin au soir tous
les jours dans les maisons d'arrêt donc
il va bien falloir qu'on trouve une
solution et je dis on parce que ce
serait bien qu'on la trouve ensemble et
que que j'espère que vous serez sensible
aux arguments que le CGL PL développe au
fur et à mesure de ses visites
c'est
c'est dommage parce que la prison
pourrait donner quelque chose
d'intelligent
pourraient ne pas être un temps mort
pourraient ne pas être cet endroit où on
passe 21h sur 24 en cellule enfermé à
trois dans moins d'un mètre carré
d'espace vital par personne je vous
rappelle que la norme européenne c'est 3
mètres carrés moi j'ai vu ça je vous
aussi d'ailleurs vous on n'est pas fier
franchement
quand je suis allée visiter les prisons
allemandes et que je les ai vu à un par
cellule 70% des détenus qui travaillent
en Allemagne contre 28% en France
il y a en Allemagne et en Hollande
huit peines de travail d'intérêt général
pour deux peines de prison ferme nous
c'est la proportion est inverse
mais pourquoi pourquoi on rate tellement
ce que d'autres réussissent et pourquoi
on ne reprend pas ça plus calmement plus
plus intelligemment plus de façon à ce
que effectivement la prison quand on en
sorte et bien qu'on y ait appris quelque
chose qu'on y ait pris le goût de
quelque chose vous savez c'est possible
j'ai entendu des détenus quand j'ai
quand j'étais quand j'assistais aux
audiences raconté avec passion des
recettes de gâteaux de je ne sais pas
quoi et dire que quand il sortirait il
serait pâtissier ou boulanger que ça
allait être magnifique j'ai vu
j'ai assisté en prison à des concours
d'éloquence peut-être que vous aussi et
c'est des moments exceptionnels j'ai
il y a 11 à 12% d'illettrés en prison
pourquoi ils n'apprennent pas à lire et
à écrire pourquoi pourquoi à cause de la
surpopulation ils n'ont accès personne
n'a accès à rien parce que tout est
contraint par le temps je vous rappelle
que l'accès aux soins et contraint
également qu'il y a des pertes de
chances du point de vue de la maladie et
de la mort de certains détenus que les
médecins nous ont qui travaillent en
prison nous ont décrit et je pense que
c'est un contentieux dont les avocats
vont s'emparer
ces pertes de chances et ses mises en
danger de la vie à la fois des
surveillants et des détenus que les
médecins nous ont également décrit
en parlant notamment de décompensation
psychique de la part des détenus comme
des surveillants